hi this is a second lecture on Markov  chains we will concentrate on developing  further the general principles and tools  behind Markov chains we will first  briefly review the main definitions and  apply them to illustrate some additional  calculations one can do as a way to warm  up  well then concentrate most of the time  on the central topic of today  steady-state behavior of chains that is  on what a Markov chain does when it runs  for a long time and on what we can say  about the probabilities of being in  different states and in order to do that  we'll review recurrent States transition  states and recurrent classes talk a bit  more about periodic States concentrate  most of the time on the convergence  theorem here and the consequence  associated with balance equations of  Markov chains and finally we will end  the lecture with an important special  class  the so called birth-death processes so  let us start